LAURENCE MORONEY:
Today I'm chatting
with Amit Chopra about
Google's Agency program
and how it works to connect
developers, customers,
and of course, agencies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Amit, we finally
got you on the show.
It's really great
to have you here.
We finally got schedules lined
up and all that kind of thing.
So tell us, what is it
that you do here at Google?
AMIT CHOPRA: Great.
Thank you, Laurence, for
having me on the show.
Super excited.
Before I jump into
what I work on,
let me give a quick introduction
of what my team actually does.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: So I'm part of
a team called the Developer
Relations Ecosystem
Team, and our team
is responsible for running
a number of very scalable
global outreach programs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: Some of them
you might have heard of,
the Google Developer groups.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Love the GDGs.
AMIT CHOPRA: Perfect.
Yeah, we have hundred--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Good call out.
AMIT CHOPRA: We have
hundreds of chapters
out there, you know, exciting
people to build apps and learn
about technologies.
We also run Woman Techmaker--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
AMIT CHOPRA: --the Launchpad
program, and the Google
Developer Experts.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Lots of good stuff.
AMIT CHOPRA: Lots of
interesting programs,
very large scale programs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now you've
added to that with the Agency
program.
AMIT CHOPRA: Yes, we have.
And the Agency
program is a program
which is specifically focused
towards development agencies.
Not ad agencies, this is
for development agencies.
I generally call that
out because it gets
kind of overloaded at times.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You get a cool
jacket to also describe it, so.
AMIT CHOPRA: Yes, you do.
We have got more
cool swag as well.
You can take some
after the show from me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's not the
only reason I had you on here.
AMIT CHOPRA: OK, perfect.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's an
added bonus, but anyway.
AMIT CHOPRA: I
came for your car.
LAURENCE MORONEY: [LAUGHS]
AMIT CHOPRA: This
is pretty nice.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So tell us
a bit more about the program.
AMIT CHOPRA: OK.
So what the program
does is identifies.
Let me give you what I call
the elevator spiel on this one.
We identify, upscale,
certify, and promote
development agencies.
That's quite a mouthful,
but it actually
summarizes almost
everything that we
do about this program
with development agencies.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, in a world
where there's a demand for
richer and richer and richer
UX, agencies play a really
important role, right?
So how is it that
you foster that?
AMIT CHOPRA: Yeah, absolutely.
In fact just to
step back a little,
the whole crux of why we
started this program was,
we were looking at--
my team focuses on making
sure that app quality comes
out really great.
Anyone who's
developing understands
what it means to build
a great Android app,
use material design,
use it in the right way.
Not just use it, but
use it correctly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
AMIT CHOPRA: And we were
seeing that a lot of apps
are not kind of following the
guidelines, UX guidelines,
things to do with
general design,
battery usage, network usage.
And we would go and talk
to a lot of developers.
We would-- through
Google Developer Summits
or through other events
that we're doing.
But what we found
was that a number
of these large organizations
are actually using agencies
to build their apps, you know?
They basically bring
somebody on board
who does the work for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
AMIT CHOPRA: And we had no
connection point for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: And
so we said, hey,
let's start a program that
works directly with them.
And this was piloted about
18 months ago back in India.
So one of my colleagues said,
I'm going to experiment.
Like in all Google things,
we're like, yeah, go for it.
And, you know, after a few
months we started looking at,
did it actually make any impact?
And yes, we started to see
a change in the app quality
coming out for these apps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
developers were outsourcing
to agencies, then it was, if
we can train the agencies,
then we can scale
out really nice.
AMIT CHOPRA: It scales
And you know, if you
train agency once,
all the clients get the benefit.
So this was very
successful in India.
Then we said, OK, let's try it
in a slightly different market.
So we went and explored
it in UK and Russia.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: They were
the other two places
where we started this thing.
The program turned out really
well in other regions as well.
And then last year
when I came and started
working on this particular
team, we scaled this out
in North America as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
AMIT CHOPRA: So we've had
a pretty good outreach
of this particular program
running in almost 17 countries
now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if somebody
wants to learn about it,
where would they go?
AMIT CHOPRA: So you
can go to our website,
developers.google.com/agency.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we'll put
a link in the description box.
AMIT CHOPRA: Yeah, we'll always
have a link in the description.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right down there.
AMIT CHOPRA: OK,
right down there.
And if you were an agency,
you can see all the benefits
that we generally
provide to an agency.
If you are part of this
particular program,
we invite you to trainings,
we arrange UX reviews,
which is something very--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really handy.
AMIT CHOPRA: --popular.
Yeah.
I mean, we can't
do a lot of them,
but we kind of identify
the right opportunities.
And make sure before
you submit an app,
we can spend some
time with you on that.
We also provide you
a lot of trainings.
Some of them are trainings
that we dedicatedly
run for agencies.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
AMIT CHOPRA: In fact,
as we are talking,
there is an event
happening in New York where
we are teaching agencies
how to run design
sprints with their clients.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
AMIT CHOPRA: So we bring
them in and we train them
on best practices.
And we also invite agencies
to a lot of other events
that my team runs
from time to time.
So training is a big focus.
All that information
is on the website.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
AMIT CHOPRA: Including a
list of certified agencies.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So before
the certified agencies-- so
if I'm an agency and
I want to find out
about these great trainings
like the one you mentioned
in New York, that's all
going to be on the site?
AMIT CHOPRA: We don't list all
the trainings on the website.
What do you need to do is,
you go there and apply.
If you're not part of the
program, submit an application.
We generally go through
an evaluation process
and make sure that
we are inviting
agencies, the right
kind of agencies,
to this kind of program.
And once you are in
the program and you've
gone through a certain
number of trainings,
we then invite you to
get certified as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So tell us about
this certification.
How is that an enhancement?
AMIT CHOPRA: Yeah, so
what certification really
is designed to do is identify
the best-of-breed agencies.
We do a thorough evaluation
of the Android apps
that they have built
over the past 18 months.
They go through a
submission process.
And it's very similar
to how we generally
go about evaluating
apps for editorials.
So that's one aspect.
We look at the
quality of the apps,
the ratings, the download.
We look at the competencies
that the team has.
So based on that overall view
that we built of the agency,
we can give them a
certification status.
And we have that list also
on our website right now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
it sounds really nice.
Like, if I'm a developer
looking to have an app built,
and as you mentioned, they're
usually going to agencies
anyway, but you're helping join
the dots so that these agencies
become, first of all, trained
and then also maybe certified.
So now if I'm a
developer, also if I'm
looking to find an agency,
can I find it on the site?
AMIT CHOPRA: You can
absolutely find it on the site.
We have a directory
of certified agencies,
and you can look them up based
on the place where you are.
And we have, at
this point, roughly
about 35 agencies that
have been certified.
We certify every six months.
So we just completed
one cycle mid-year.
And so our list is
available on the website.
You can take a look.
You can contact the agencies
directly from there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
AMIT CHOPRA: And
these are the ones
that we have worked with
over a period of time
to feel fairly confident
about what they're doing
and what they're building.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's a
great benefit if I need an app,
that I can find a
certified agency that's
been certified by Google--
AMIT CHOPRA: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --to be able
to build a great app for them.
And if I'm an
agency and I can get
into that certified
program, it helps me
to find new customers, right?
AMIT CHOPRA: Absolutely.
It's a huge benefit, I think,
not just getting more business.
Being certified definitely helps
an agency get more business,
and we're hoping that that
is the case, but I think--
I especially focus a lot
on upscaling the agencies.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: A lot of
trainings we have done
have been at a very
developer level, you know?
Even teaching them some ins and
outs of using Android Studio.
This saves them a lot of This
has been one of the factors
that has drawn a lot of
agencies to our training program
as well where we can give them
these best practices that,
on a day to day basis, help
them save a lot of time, right?
And that's value.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, definitely.
AMIT CHOPRA: I mean,
that's the value
we're adding for them as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, you started
in India, then you
extended to Russia
and the UK, and then
you've come to North America.
I'm sure there's some
great success stories.
AMIT CHOPRA: Absolutely,
lots of them.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Always inspired
by the success stories.
AMIT CHOPRA: Always, yeah.
So what we actually did was,
with the success stories,
we have started what we call
as the Spotlight video series.
You know, we go out to
these certified agencies,
we spend some time
and talk to them
about the kind of projects
they have worked on,
the interesting things
that they have done.
A lot of them are
project-dependent,
but I think one interesting
one, and you can actually see
the TechGenie spotlight
video on that as well--
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AMIT CHOPRA: --was
one of the dev leads.
You know, she said that she
went on a maternity leave,
and when she came
back her team was
so well-trained because they had
been attending these trainings.
She was really surprised.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
AMIT CHOPRA: She
comes out really
well in terms of
sharing her experiences.
So there are interesting
soft stories,
success stories around certain
aspects of how the agency has
benefited the agency.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Excellent.
AMIT CHOPRA: Also a
lot of case studies
that are in the
spotlight videos that
talk about how they were able
to get UX reviews, for example,
and then get an app out much
faster for the clients, which
is beneficial to the client
and also for the clients' end
users, people like you and me
who have to use their apps.
They see a very
consistent design,
they see a very robust
app that you can use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So if I want to learn more, it's
developer.google.com/agency?
AMIT CHOPRA: /agency.
And it's all down there
in the description,
as you called out before.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right there.
AMIT CHOPRA: Yeah, right there.
And if you're an
agency, go sign up.
You know, we have a
show interest form.
And, you know, it's not running
in all the countries right now,
but gradually we
are expanding that.
The expansion, in fact, to
Brazil is coming up very soon.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
AMIT CHOPRA: So we'll be signing
up agencies in that region.
And gradually we'll move
to other parts of the world
as well as we're starting to
see interest from the agencies
worldwide.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
never too late to sign up.
AMIT CHOPRA: Never too late
to sign up, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thanks so much, Amit.
I've really learned a lot.
AMIT CHOPRA: Thank
you, Laurence.
This was great to be here, and
talk to you about the program
and talk to our audiences
about the program as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds
like a great program.
So thanks for watching
this episode of Coffee
With A Googler.
If you want to learn more
about the Agency program,
just take a look at the
links in the comments below.
And if you have any
questions for me
or any questions for
Amit, just leave them
in the YouTube comments.
Thank you so much.
AMIT CHOPRA: Thank
you very much.